Hello, laser and holography enthusiasts, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk.
This is a special broadcast this week.
In fact, we have a special guest, Todd Stark, who is director of programs and exhibits for the Discovery Center of Science and Technology in Bethlehem, Pennsylvania.
And as you may recall, if you've listened to our shows in the past, you know for probably six or eight weeks now we've been talking about a traveling exhibit of lasers and holograms.
It's coming to the Lehigh Valley area that's been put together by Pacific Science Center.
And we're going to host it at the Discovery Center of Science and Technology.
Well, Todd took some time to come into the studio this week and sit down so that HoloTalk listeners can get firsthand information and some detailed information on what this exhibit is all about.
One of the things that we did not touch on, and I promised Todd I would mention, is there's going to be a smaller exhibit that goes along with this.
There's a few students in the Lehigh Valley who received a grant to put together a Star Trek exhibit on where lasers and holograms will be in the 24th century, sort of a futuristic look at lasers and holograms.
And I just want to let you know that that's going to be included also in the exhibit when you would come out to see the main exhibit.
And I had a chance to see the model this week from one of the students.
They put a model together when they applied for the grant.
And it's very nice.
It's a very nice little exhibit that you're going to put together.
So don't forget to check out the Star Trek laser and hologram exhibit that runs along with this if you come out to the Discovery Center.
Excuse me.
So as far as details, Todd's going to fill us in on that.
And there's also a link on the HoloTalk page where you can click on that link.
And there's a page at the Web ZM that I put up today to show you a few pictures that uh were sent out in the press kit and also give you some more information.
And you can get on a mailing list uh for email list.
Every so often we'll send out some information.
Uh perhaps there's an uh special programs uh that we're going to run or uh maybe even a special side exhibit of amateur and hobbyist holograms.
And there's a lot of things that can take place between now and when this opens in June.
So if you want to have all the latest information, just click on the link on the laser and hologram page, and every so often you'll receive an email which will give you updated information on what's happening.
So let's move on to the interview with Todd Stark.
I'm not going to come back on uh at the end, so let me at this time say thank you for tuning in, and here's the interview with Todd Stark.
Okay, we're in the studio uh with Todd Stark, who is the uh director of programs and exhibits at the Discovery Center of Science and Technology, which is in Bethlehem, Pennsylvania.
Todd, I want to welcome the whole talk.
Well, welcome.
Thank you, uh Frank.
Thanks for having me.
Um we're going to be talking about the new exhibit that's coming into the area, and it's very exciting.
If you may remember we had an exhibit that traveled through this uh what we call the Northeast Carter um probably a few years ago at the Franklin Institute in Philadelphia, which was Lasers, holograms and virtual reality.
And since then we've been in a uh quite a bit of a dry spell.
And it's a wonderful opportunity for everyone in this area to come out and finally have another major exhibit of lasers and holograms in this area.
Now, I know you were involved uh with Kosai, which was the uh touring company behind what the uh exhibit was in f in Philadelphia.
Is there some comparisons, uh things that are the same, things that are different that you could maybe uh let some of the listeners know about?
Sure.
Um well Liquid Vision, which was the uh the official name of that exhibit that was traveled in in Franklin was there uh about three and a half years ago on its opening tour.
And um it was it's very so much centered around the high tech industry and oh by the way had holograms that it showed.
It had a really nice collection of holograms and that this exhibit here, lasers and holograms uh traveled by the Pacific Science Center out of Seattle, Washington, uh focuses more on getting to understand how holograms are created, what you can do with holograms, um, what their interactions are with lasers, the importance of lasers in our lives, um, how they work, how to do laser shows and that.
So in the area of lasers and holograms, this exhibit here is much more interactive than the Liquid Vision exhibition, which tended to stray more toward the the three-dimensional computer graphics and um high tech glitz and and that but dealt very little with the actual holograms themselves.
From what I've been able to see with the the promotional materials that I've had it seems to me that this is happening at just the right time.
Uh some of the past hologram exhibits that had traveled around such as the one in Philadelphia and also images in time and space which did its uh round in Canada and out on the West Coast was more of a wow look at this type of an exhibit.
Now I think we're moving beyond that and we're saying okay we've been wild.
Tell us how is this going to affect our lives?
How is this going to affect our children's decision as far as career someday?
Can my child go out and actually support a family or whatever it is that they want to do in these fields?
And I think that's where we're moving at, and and this is definitely one of the focal points of this exhibit, which is called, by the way, Lasers and Holograms Exploring the Splendid Light.
And it's a touring exhibit by Pacific Science Center.
And uh do you want to take a few moments and do you do you have an idea of what some of these little interactive exhibits are that the people tell us a little bit if someone were to come out and uh I guess they could spend quite a bit of time going around each and every little station, but what are some of the highlights that they can expect to see if they come out to the Discovery Center?
Right.
Well, you know, I happen to agree with you, uh Frank on on the wow factor for holograms, I think is passed.
Uh you know, since we're finding holograms on our driver's licenses and uh credit cards and that, um, there are more and more applications for lasers and holograms.
Um, you know, we we there's going to be, I think there's over 18 large-scale holograms, very impressive um pictures, um, some from holographics north to um private producers and that uh in there, but that's not the focus, that's not the feature of it.
It's it's sort of complementary to the exhibits and hands-on activities that we've got going on there.
Um with this exhibit, uh we look into the world of fiber optics.
You know, lasers and holograms are are linked, of course, really closely, and um fiber optics is the next step in in telecommunications.
Um it's it's most of what's carrying the net as it is now, but very few people have a true understanding of what fiber optics is and that.
It has a huge display on a very large-scale fiber optic piece, allows you to look through it as if you were looking through that gr glass rod, um, if you were a light beam uh going through it.
Um they've got a little uh kiosk that allows you to mix your own little laser light show of course you know lasers aren't just professional use but are for entertainment value as well um they have um in the areas of h holograms they talk about um what it what diffraction uh gradings and diffraction uh images are and interference patterns um how they're creating and how that helps create the illusion of an a hologram um they've got other exhibits that uh let's see that deal with um everyday applications you know lasers and cds and and writable and and readable CD ROMs things that are happening in the background that you don't see is happening with lasers right in your own home exactly um one of the other exhibits that had traveled with it uh but uh for technical difficulties in there was a a barcode reader from a supermarket and and that you know another application of of lasers.
So the kids are really going to get in and interact with several different smaller scale components dealing with different facets of of lasers and uh applications of lasers in their everyday lives and the creation of holograms.
They have a holographic cable that allows you to literally trace a actual laser beam throughout it.
I see in the making of the hologram.
In the making of a hologram.
You can look through it and see the hologram image being made on the plate.
They've got another one where you can study the um uh study how lasers are used to test and measure things.
Uh they've got a steel plate, the laser beam goes out and if you press on the plate you can actually see it the the calibration change.
Oh that's the interferometer.
Interferometry, yeah, thank you.
That's yes.
And uh that's covered as well.
So there's a lot of great little application.
It's going to be a really fun glitzy ex uh exhibit and we hope to complement it with some some wonderful program programmatic aspects that we'll be developing over the next couple months.
Well maybe maybe we should touch a little bit on what information you have now about some of the in uh educational programs that will be available.
The Discovery Center of Science and Technology is is very dedicated in not just having students come in and see science but experience it and show them how they can move on later in their life as far as career decisions.
And I understand you're going to be running a series of summer programs that will center right around careers of science and technology and will also include the careers of lasers and holograms during that week.
Could you tell us a little about that?
That is correct.
We're running of course our week long summer camp as many uh institutions like ourselves do throughout the country.
Um this year we're focusing on um become a scientist for a day and we've picked uh several different scientists careers uh biologist uh chemist zoologist uh geologist uh of course uh laser and holographers um computer specialists and we're going to explore explore those through wonderful hands-on interactive activities uh experiments uh games uh throughout the week and we're kind of devoting half days to uh a series a number of different careers and it's sort of just to get the kids uh what their appetites into you know if I if I want to grow up and I want to be a scientist, what kind of cool things can I get involved in and as you said, lasers and holograms is going to be featured uh during part of that day and uh hopefully the kids will get a better understanding of what it takes to make a laser and and or take to make a hologram.
Um what kind of things, how can they make money, you know, using lasers and and stuff that they think that's really cool.
Uh so exploring those avenues um with our uh six to twelve year olds is is where we're headed with that.
Okay.
Um I'd also like to point out to people that some of the holograms that are going to be on exhibit, believe it or not, didn't start out as just holograms, but began during the photographic process with traditional photography, which are called s uh holographic stereograms.
So if you're a photographer or part of a 3D stereo group which seemed to be cropping up and becoming uh very uh popular lately, uh you definitely want to stop over to the uh Discovery Center and see some of these because some of these holograms originally started with a photographic process, not just holographic.
Um a series of photographs are taken from different perspectives, and then those photographs are processed in the traditional manner, uh, some actually are used uh with digital technology, but they're then brought into the laboratory, and all those different perspectives are actually digitized and brought into the holographic process where you have a uh three-dimensional hologram as the final product.
So uh this is not that far away from photography, and I know we have a lot of uh photography uh clubs and amateur and hobbyist photographers out there, and I I'm sure that you would be absolutely thrilled to see uh what's possible to do with your own camera and then have those pictures made into a three-dimensional hologram.
Um the dates, would you like to tell us about dates and times, uh, hours of operation and how we can uh get in touch with you if you want some more information?
I I know we're gonna put some information on the web.
There's gonna be some information right at the uh webzium for everybody coming through, and the Discovery Center also has uh its own site.
So Todd, why don't you fill us in on how we can get more information on this?
Sure.
Um the Lasers and Holograms uh exhibition will be running this summer.
It will open up on Saturday, June sixth, uh to the general public and will run all the way through September, uh Sunday, September thirteenth.
So be here all summer.
Your chance to check it out.
Um you'll be you can catch us at the Discovery Center uh Tuesdays through Saturdays, uh 9 30 to 4 30 and Sundays 1230 to um 430.
Um we're very reasonably priced, uh in the center of the valley, of course we've got the regular um Discovery Center uh exhibits and um you can get in at uh adult prices four fifty, uh kids under twelve or three fifty and uh children uh three and under are free.
Um the uh lasers and holograms exhibition will cost just an extra dollar fifty per person.
And of course while you're there you can also check out our laser show that we're producing.
Um this year we've managed to uh through a funding source get some upgrades and some equipment.
Allows us to do some animated um programs.
So we're going to be doing a laser light show.
We're producing it right now um as uh amateur um laser show producer.
This is uh becoming quite a learning experience.
I've seen some of the stuff, it's pretty cool.
Yeah, it is pretty cool and it is amazing what they're able to do now uh nowadays.
Um we'll be telling the story of how uh laser shows are are made through the actual laser show itself.
There you go.
There's a unique use.
Uh educational.
We're not just doing it's rock music.
We're not going to be able to do that.
No, it's out with a learning experience.
And be entertained at the same time.
And that's what we're trying to do with it.
Okay.
I I was going to give you a laser.
What I want to let people know, and I don't know if they're they know this or not, but believe it or not, if you live in the New York, Philadelphia, Baltimore, Washington, DC, corridor, you can get to the Discovery Center of Science and Technology without even experiencing a red light until you're only a several blocks away from the actual center.
Of course, uh y you would get on ninety five north and we'll have some specific directions for you.
But I know a lot of times with summer traffic, construction, all these other things and people just say, look, this trip is just too long, you know, don't worry about it.
Once you're on ninety five, unless you want to stop to grab something to eat or you choose to stop, you will not even experience a red light until you're what about three blocks away from the center.
That's just about right.
And so it's almost door to door.
So uh no excuse if you live far away, jump in the car and come on up.
The laser light show is is uh but we we had a laser light show there.
It was uh uh a laser light show that uh I guess low scale is is a good word for I without I can't think of the term.
But it it produced all those little legerious patterns and whatever and L.
Michael Roberts is actually going to be a guest on the show so he'll probably be able to tell us what these things mean uh in in a couple of weeks.
Uh but uh the laser light show that they have now is a professional system that's done through a computer system and runs very high speech scanners and uh is capable of drawing out animations and words and telling stories and it's all part of your experience uh when you come to the Discovery Center.
And uh like we said before, it's not just an entertainment experience, but you learn something and believe it or not, a lot of times you go out in the car and you hit yourself in your head and you didn't even realize you learned it.
And you did.
So uh any closing remarks you'd like to make to uh the Holo Talk listeners before we uh head out here?
Well I think uh for any of the uh hologram enthusiasts I think uh trip to the Discovery Center uh to see this collection of holograms and hopefully complimented by some other amateur uh holography ham amateur and professional holograms that we'll hopefully have there uh will make a very rewarding and very worthwhile experience uh for anyone that is in the hologram uh holography business or holography interests and and lasers and that and uh you know the Discovery Center is not just for kids it's for kids of all ages.
Um anyone the kids at heart and loves to learn and loves to look at wow cool neat stuff and and actually learn a little something along the way.
Okay, and before I say goodbye to Todd I'm gonna add one more thing to this and that I hear a lot of times emails from people what's happening with holography, where can I see holograms?
There's nothing happening in the area with holograms.
Here's your opportunity.
And who knows when it's going to happen again.
So if you don't come up and see this show, don't send me any emails whining about the fact that you can't see any holograms anymore because I I'm just gonna delete them.
I'm not going to even answer them.
Now's your opportunity.
If you don't take advantage of it shame on you.
So Todd thank you very much for being on the Frank and uh we look forward to this and personally a thank you from me for giving uh lasers and holograms uh an opportunity to c come into the area for people to experience it.
And thank you from the Holo Talk listeners as well.
Take care.
Thank you.